one team that definitely appears to need
the running back are the Dallas Cowboys
right now their leading rusher is in
Cabo San Lucas joining us right now to
discuss this issue from Cowboys camp one
of my favorite people on planet earth
he's a pro Football Hall of Famer what
makes his point he figuratively twists
your arm and clearly he literally did it
to Stephen a Smith on first take
yesterday because Stephen a Smith was in
his sling it's Michael Irvin Irv did you
do that - Stephen a did you do that - no
I told a man I said I come in with this
rotator cuff thing going on and I hope
you didn't come in here with that thing
thinking that swing thinking mercy would
be you ever heard there was no mercy
delivery I don't care about arm being in
a sling but yeah you do you know I was
we had to go at it always on the Cowboys
a rich would you just say it rich is
what it's really all about everybody
wants to cook every running backs in a
box in this lead when the reality is
okay so if 25 teams are using running
back by committee I guarantee there's 25
teams that would be geologists are a
lady on bail or a sacrum Barclays you
cannot continue we cannot continue to
put these elite guys and keep them
measured to these group of guys that
they wish they were said that other guys
wish they had guys like these army guys
you just got to stop doing it in and
that you guys a fight for their money
well and before we get I guess deeper
into that issue you know Jerry Jones
bringing up the fact that Emmitt Smith
was the last leading rusher to win a
Super Bowl in the same year he did
forget our colleague Terrell Davis to do
it in 98 but all three of your years
winning the Super Bowl
Emmitt led the league in rushing and
we're gonna hear it again a Jerry kind
of even alluded to it yesterday Michael
was the 93 holdout where they lost the
first two games yes but it would
business was business and they finally
did come to an agreement and the Cowboys
won the Super Bowl anyway do you
that is in any way shape or form what
Jerry's playing out here with Ezekiel
Elliott in 2019 you know that's one of
the things that I was hesitant to talk
about yesterday too so I don't want to
put it in the ether and think that the
ether was slipping towards here but now
that I hear it it is why I was concerned
you look at the Giants you'll get a red
eye problems get past these first couple
gangs but the reality is I hope I hope
that's just negotiations what he's doing
right now
where he's saying these things hoping
these things get back to Z and they come
down on a number it's just negotiations
because you don't want to go into this
situation where the Cowboys everybody's
so positive about the possibilities of
this season and then said we're going to
start thinking without at CCO Elliot I
think that'll be tough work out so what
advice would you give Zeke if he's
sitting there right now in Cabo taken in
this show or he sees it later on what
advice would you offer state going to
Kabul to Train is like saying well I
think I'm gonna go to Vegas and pray
pray without be not really else training
the cobbles I just don't know if that's
really but that being said want me to
say something to speak with the
situation is what it is rich I mean I'm
not saying a Zika is wrong I'm just
saying I hope I wish it wasn't happening
because I'm a cowboy fan yes but I'm not
saying I think is wrong to be turning
totally honest with you I mean if you're
one of the top guys in this league and
you are obviously wanting top guys
nobody has touched the ball more than
you with any other letters by their name
except poopy except QB that's it Cuba
Cuba touch the ball in every play
alright the next person out there is
this DQ Elliot and everybody keeps
talking about how beef is winning
champion no coach winning championships
and get once you got to take that
football and get across the goal line
and that's what the yelling it does as
you know Michael Irvin did these things
don't just happen in a vacuum everybody
gets asked about it over and over and
over again what was it like for you when
M it was
in 93 that might be another allegory to
to draw upon for the 2019 training camp
here well you go into the season thing
okay we can get this game just like the
travels are probably thinking man we
probably beat the Giants we could
probably beat the Redskins and then you
don't you don't understand and you
underestimate exactly what that means
you get in a game and it's and it's
third in two or something we hand the
ball off and you don't get that first
down
and it's one thing not to get the first
down but it's nothing not to get the
first down in walking toward the
sidelines and it would have gotten that
man I mean we're a little short-handed
now the thing starts climbing in your
head and it's just a bad situation it
was a bad situation I think we still
should have been some of the being a
couple of Buffalo we could've beat those
teams without him it but it was in our
head said he wasn't there and every time
you line up in the huddle you would
always look towards the locker room
hoping or thinking he's going to come
out of that locker room he never did
Michael Irvin calling in from Oxnard
California side of Cowboys training camp
about to hit NFL Network's inside
training can't live for a few hours from
there right here on the Rich Eisen show
before before going that route so what
do you think Jerry's thinking here
Michael I mean you you you you you're
worse your verse to your fluent in in
Jones business acumen here I mean what
do you think he's trying cuz we all know
Zeke is a crucial element of this team
and what what is it play here do you
think I think we'll get something done
that's what he is that's what he does
Jerry understands business more than
anybody not a work business this is what
they love doing rich this is see what it
does to a player it's different than
what it does like Jerry loves
negotiating stuff it messes with the
players here because no matter what the
players still sitting back saying oh oh
they don't think I work oh do you know
what I mean and you have to be careful
that those feelings don't linger
they don't linger
and you bring them with you and your
whole grudges against people but but
Jerry loves this stuff I I just hope he
has the plan I hope he has a plan I
don't expect anything to get done or to
slip and falls off Cinderella that's
usually when everything gets done when
the super falls off Cinderella and
everybody starts panicky
that's just what how big business work
but I'm expecting something to get done
I don't see Jared sending themself
short-handed into the season but don't
you think the Cowboys have already
proven to to xik that they that they do
want them that they do support him I
mean of everything that he's gone
through or put the organization through
to use that phrasing of it don't you
think that the committe Cowboys have
already communicated that yeah no doubt
no doubt that they've shown great
support and great love but but Z says
show me one more time and this time show
me with the money you know support but I
need you to show me one more time and
show me with the money any Cowboys think
I was the thing I'm willing to do that
we just can't give you all the money
right now
but it's interesting how you say that
Jerry enjoys this stuff and obviously
that makes sense when you know when
you're a negotiator for as a profession
it seems you know for for Jerry but to
me I mean look Mike your this is it
right that Cowboys defenses is ready to
roll I mean on that side of the ball
they are animals and they're fast and
they're good and the Cowboys you know
are set to go here and you got the
offensive line back Irv right and you've
got and you've got Amari Cooper may be
about to get done if not that's that's
okay I guess but there's dak - he's
gonna get done ready to go and Kellen
Moore they brought him in because
according to all reports I'm seeing from
James Slater or Kali that they saw there
Shawn McVeigh they wanted their young
guy they got their young guy this is it
why are we messing about why are we
messing around here right all that
you're saying and all that we're saying
is exactly what Zeke saying and he's
saying that's why I have to do this
right now he understands look at the
manscape
they're going to rub me these next two
years and then franchise their get a
three years now I'm done probably it's
how he's looking at it and right now
everything is right on the edge ready to
be pushed towards that Super Bowl this
is I'm at the height of my leverage I
have to try to get something done right
here right now and I have people saying
you know you got to get back down
that'll be my first priority but a
martyr's make it 14 times in a year
right now
14 million this season I'm gonna hold
back on a marsh and a tomorrow and and
and it now now that's a dangerous thing
too because Michael Thomas coming up yep
Oh Julio Jones getting a new deal so
whatever number you think you can get a
marvel right now that number is going to
change house so it's just the reality of
what's going to happen because that
number that number is going to move but
I but I would get back done and I will
get it done
and I thought least get this on the
chant on on the field right now
what does this offense gonna look like
oh do you got a sense here how
difference are gonna be assuming Z comes
back here what do we got on the show you
just talked about Sean rebate what
they're looking for i Kellen Moore
they're looking for that but dowser
awesome everybody wants that but the
house office but what happens rich with
with with their are with the Rams but
the house will often they get people out
of position because there's so much
movement and then they leave Gloucester
on people so they have a bedazzled
offense that gives people out of
position that sometimes makes them look
physical makes it look physical until
until their genius we call Bill
Belichick says okay forget looking for
school I want to see if you really can
be sociable in the last two phones that
the Rams Canadians they both are losses
to that man call Bill Belichick because
they had a bedazzled office can look but
when he got physical with him they could
not win that football game now if the
Cowboys can add but thousand to their
offense the bill and bedazzled to
authors that really is
go they don't have to look they don't
make it look like they're physical it
really they really are a physical office
and that that's a hard office to thought
when you have four thousand outside in
football yeah me Randall Cobb has been
added to the mix Michael I mean right
and you and obviously Tavon Austin is is
part of the bedazzled that you're you're
discussing that's why I just don't
understand just get it done get it done
and let's go
I mean the Cowboys are set I'll be
honest Michael you know how I love
having fun at your expense about the
Cowboys on NFL gameday morning this is
the tenth year that I'm hosting that
show so it's been ten years of a decade
of me having a lot of fun at your
expense this is truly the first time
I've come into a season where I think
the Cowboys can do it for real the guy
who's sitting in Cabo in and they make
doc heavy pocketed and I'm ready I'm
ready to believe I just can't I can't
get there right now I can't get there
right now well not without the keikain
that's just reality over which it's hard
to get there without Zeke Manning and
and and I thought that's just a reality
all right to say how do we get this team
because you have a scene in a human so
much and so many different ways rich and
he's always always there he's always
ready to play he doesn't get hurt he's
always be so physical and you need with
that offensive line there's a matrimony
that goes on between running back and
officer line and people keep talking so
pretty anywhere in fact back there might
stop you cannot do that there's a
matrimony and and it keeps in his
patient the way he runs is perfect for
this offensive line yeah III just hope
they get it right going into this I love
how you say you hope so I'm the last one
for you here because when you say you
hope we can't know for sure and I'm sure
I don't know you just pulled into town
you haven't pulled him aside and and and
so what's going so my question for you
is which Jerry Jones wins out the one
that knows that his team said
and and the one that knows I I know I
got a guy who you know on occasion can't
stay home at night certainly when he
goes to Vegas and and he's maybe one
more slip-up away from not being there
but I gotta pay him or the guy was like
you know what I I went into 93 without
Emmitt Smith you know the leading rusher
of all time and I got it done late and
we still want it all which which guy
wins out do you think here you know what
you say it you went into 93 93 rich 93
and the last bully one like at 95 95
that tells you everything which which
with cherries on should without you talk
about 95 95 you don't have time to mess
around but it you got the most values
franchise by fours right there right now
you go win that Super Bowl right now you
have an opportunity best opportunities
you had since probably 95 stands right
before you right now I think the reason
the reasoning JP Jones Jerry Jones that
says they said does a couple a couple
couple months ago well you guys will be
embarrassed to hear about how big of a
check I would write to win this Super
Bowl what's yours you said it and now
it's time to write it love you're seeing
Canton alright buddy love you too man
you got it that's Michael Irvin Hall of
Famer for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app